don't want to focus on one man for the
sake of just humiliating someone much as
he may deserve it
but as a metaphor for what is happening
in this country the people making the
rules
aren't following them but they're
certainly enforcing them
in your case in new york city for
example officials are working hard to
harass the very few businesses that have
maintained
open doors a video uploaded on twitter
on tuesday shows health inspectors
issuing a citation to a restaurant
because its front door was open on a hot
day
if you don't want to you don't need to
sign it i know you're recording me
that's fine i'm allowed to record you
i'm going to give you a copy then you're
giving me a ticket because my doors are
open sir
there's nobody sitting in the restaurant
everything is okay you're giving me a
ticket because my doors are open
what if my store is hot i'm not allowed
to open the door because the store is
hot
everything's fell down in the summons
i'm going to give you a copy
you know i'm struggling here every
single day it's hard for me
and there was nobody inside the store
obviously because we don't have dining
we only have takeout there was nobody in
the store
and i'm only getting a ticket because my
doors are open
jacob green is the owner of the
restaurant you just saw he's a cousin of
the man in the video the restaurant is
called mixed greens cafe it's in
brooklyn
jacob green joins us today ms green
thanks so much for coming on
what do you think that was about it
didn't seem like you were endangering
anyone
uh no it's really it's kind of crazy
because there was nobody in the
restaurant
and aside from that you know when he
came in he came in as a plain clothes
person as to sit down and eat
and my cousin uh the manager told him uh
you know i'm sorry we're only take out
and uh delivery uh then he pulled out
his badge and then
he proceeded to write the summons and he
saw my cousin i mean he was
brokenhearted
um you know because he really you know
he runs this place and he loves it
and uh he just couldn't understand why
he was getting this citation
and you know the person was giving him
absolutely no information at all
and you know he wasn't yelling or
screaming or throwing something he was
very very kind and you know you could
hear that he was hurt in his voice
um you know we worked so hard
uh and we were struggling to begin with
because of covid and
it's really uh it's really disheartening
you know when
your business is already so slow because
of this and then somebody walks in
and issues you a citation he called me
up literally you know on the verge of
tears
not understanding what's going on um
you know and again to debate whether to
stay open or not to begin with it
it's it's amazing and the thing that
baffles me most
is that i'm in a red zone but if i want
to go eat in a red zone restaurant is
closed
i'm going to a different restaurant
outside of the red zone
or if i want to buy a pair of shoes i'm
going to a different shoe store
so what what's going on here our schools
are closed our synagogues are closed
you know small businesses are suffering
um
and and really there's no progress being
made because you could really just go
anywhere else it's not like they lock
you in your house if you're in the red
zone and say you can't go anywhere you
still have freedom to move and work
so it's it's baffling to me it really is
meanwhile people are hiring the subway
because it's so dangerous really really
quickly why do you think
when women are literally afraid to get
on the subway and people are living on
the street
and defecating in trash cans and making
a mess of our biggest city
why are they picking on you
really i i i have no idea i have no idea
you know um but i i will say that after
this whole thing happened
uh the uh it was rescinded the uh
summons
uh which heim deutsche was uh uh you
know
the councilman was uh instrumental in
that and he said that uh
if any other small businesses are having
the same issues he wants to help them
out
and fight it as well um it's just uh the
outpouring of support we've had is
is really something that i've never seen
before i and i really believe that
america is the greatest country to live
in um you know i have people ordering
online
shoot no i i think you're absolutely
right marcus
you're brave to to film that and to put
it on this show and we're grateful that
you did people need to see it jacob
green thank you
oh my pleasure thank you so much